alors non mais est ce que vous vous avez
déjà vu un admirateur ou quelqu'un que
vous aimez vous admiriez en secret jeudi
a dit la vérité à moi j'ai déjà admirer
en secret effectivement quelqu'un j'ai
comme tout le monde j'avais déjà ce
plateau il est notre bouche et pour
tenir malick mais d'un point de vue
amicale nationale est absolument pas
physique sont donnés rendez vous dire
que cette émission c'est pour faire sa
déclaration d'amour et pas d'impôts à
l'impôt d'amour uniquement alors je dois
je coûte une bourgade aussi on ne parle
que d'amour dans cette émission et c'est
forcément des gens que vous connaissez
donc un voisin une amie de longue date
akrou vous allez faire votre déclaration
jacques bour jury non mais c'est
formidable vous savez peut-être harry
potter un mois arrive à le dire ci alors
seront benjamin castaldi est ce que
maintenant vous où vous avez 18 femmes
non est-ce que vous avez quelqu'un moi
j'ai quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup
non c'est vrai j'avais fait un texte ah
oui à easy on va essayer de trouver de
qui il s'agit
je voudrais en ce moment d'avoir sans
mes genoux et couvrir la bouche divine
de baisers mais comment faire avec ton
nez vérité véritable muraille de chine
sans limite
on ne sait comment la contourner alors
continue à me souffle et des motos avec
ta voix qui me rappelle avec émotion
celle de chewbacca
j'ai dit je t'aime à la voilà vous étiez
là jamais j'avais fait un coup de
pression à la hanouna ya quelques années
au téléphone non mais si je te nique
chez vous s'est pas prononcé ces moines
ne sais pas ce que c'est beaucoup trop
tendre voilà on s'est dit les choses
de plus vous êtes très amis et on est
très peur et on s'appelle le week end
dit la vérité moi je veux des ombres est
ce que vous avez vous franchement maxime
oui j'écris quelque chose ailleurs à toi
faire le quelqu'un autour de la table
quoi quelqu'un tomber un cadre où toyota
motor publie dans cette salle attend
cette année
[Applaudissements]
je connais mal à lévis chères
demoiselles aussi ces montages aussi
indicible soit-il ton charme et la
valeur sûre et grandissante de ta
personnalité tu a privilégié sa carrière
au profit de ta vie sentimentale et
pourtant tu as tellement a donné ouvre
toi
ouvre ton coeur ou là elle a privilégié
sa carrière au détriment de sa vie
sentimentale
ouais j'en sais que ce n'est pas bénin
oui alors oui ouvre toi
ouvre ton coeur regarde-moi regarde la
douceur de vivre à l'intérieur un regard
un sourire oui ton prénom est une
ritournelle qui esquisse bisous bisous
psps l'avenir 3rbds de belles surprises
avec moi ou pas daniel débrouille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et toi tu es très hétérogène président
héros qui est passé de kenny à daniel
grand écart c'est le grand écart et
c'est le même délire cgt 90 ans il ou
pas lui faire un petit smack
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'agglo
lang
[Applaudissements]
google a écrit jack un maximum ça fait
moins dense mais pas 100 smac c'était
joli quoi il a une belle bouche
non non mais la déclaration extrêmement
touché par la déclaration de certains
rendez compte à 20 ans tu t'es quoi
c'est demain alors aujourd'hui ne me
parlez plus d'âge
franchement tout le monde peut sortir
avec tout le monde sur l'un des
résidents et mes bras macron ils ont de
bons lots et des pitchous sur cette
partie du monde après son travail la
nuit
j'aurais jamais vraiment vous avez un
gilet qui peut plaire à cet artiste est
quand même beaucoup plus que son âge et
et moi il pareil je bouge pas parce que
vous êtes magnifique ça fait longtemps
que je dis est ce que vous vous avez
quelqu'un que vous amis mairesse
secrètement ouais mais puisque je suis
un peu timide et là j'ai écrit un petit
petit quelque chose
apparemment c'est pas lui alors ben non
mais c'est pour ça même avec daniel et
endemol a commencé oui parce que lui il
a pas dit si c'est uniquement sexuelle
je colle au collet en écoutant bien vous
avez deviné assez vite h au dos je te
fais ce poème espérant qu'ils te
plaisent car en face de toi je ne suis
pas à l'aise pour avouer mon amour je me
sentirai niel pourtant je suis troublé
par ton regard de braise des propos
mesurés à la télé m'apaise étant bien
trop timide il faut que je me taise
mais ça devient urgent alors quand
est-ce qu'on
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas depuis sa vie alors c'est
sûr chelsea sait pas d'âge avait pas
trouvé d'autres images verdez
la libre à côté parce que le nom mais
des vraies mais sexy les humains
physiquement c'est quand même jour et la
plus acclamée attendait pas regarder si
vous faites un enfant j'en veux 6
[Rires]
alors si je suis raisonnable je vais
avec maxime
oui je veux me faire un petit déclic
plaisir c'est excitant quoi c'est vrai
mais j'ai jamais eu l'air de vous
étonner mais pas de bye bye que j'irai
là bas qui est pas tout
ça passe par des bulles et on a ça passe
gilles est ce que daniel aurait pas être
mon style ah oui dans un autre monde
[Rires]
une autre période situe alors si tu
casses avec fatou pourquoi pas acheteurs
car il est mort je pense pas que ça se
produise mais pourquoi pas daniel à
quelque chose d'exceptionnel baba se
dégage d'elle quelque chose c'est vrai
un parfum de sexe parfum de sexe oui
c'est donc dépassé je suis chez ses
parents bah bravo ça alors qu'il est
vraiment cretin cali oui moi j'essaie et
oui chez lui vous êtes aussi mais on a
appris quelque chose à l'audience avec à
toi on fait gaffe j'ai pris alors vas-y
cher ami hassan amid hélas rien n'est
censé nous rassembler rien ne peut nous
rapprocher mais chaque pas de ta vie m'a
comblé chaque combat de ton parcours à
fortifier deux planètes censée ne jamais
se rencontrer deux âmes qui ont grandi
comme des guerriers puisqu'à force me
protéger piston parcourant me réconforte
non c'est vrai pour moi c'est pour ces
raisons que c'est le monsieur
non mais il n'oublie rien maintenant je
sais qui c'est elle m'a parlé de son
baiia je suis actuellement et je ne peux
pas le dire mais la personne se
reconnaîtra et la personne c'est d'eux
qu'il salue ses bouder
le repos est à l'heure où elle s'est pas
dans des pelles pizza alors un claudio
claudine est ce que toi toi tu étais et
était mariée et je suis pas marié non
confiance et nous invite au mariage
bah si tu veux pas ce problème je peux
pas te voir dany brillant j'adore
j'adore je te mets qui tu veux tu me dis
que tu veux sur le chemin est donc toi
t'as pas d'admiratrices secrète ben
écoute j'admire j'admire mes parents tu
vois assez bon si tous les joueurs
[Applaudissements]
aiment aussi j'admire ces parents donc
[Rires]
on n'y a pas quoi sert pas non non non
il ya toujours osé dire t'es senti -
qu'est-ce que celui de quoi non mais n'a
jamais été amoureux est à jamais ne pas
oser dire ce que tu ressentais pour une
personne proche de toi
non non a toujours fait des déclarations
comme ça même pas peur non même pas où
il va directement vers la vente directe
le connaît oui j'ai passé des soirs avec
le problème alors je vous raconter une
histoire parce que je lis tout ce soir
at le problème nord mais t'inquiète pas
non même façon en pleine de malik
bentalha c'est que quand il est sur une
meuf
il veut que y est tous ses potes qui
viennent avec lui la compagnie presto
qui t'appelle à le soir c'est vrai est
ce que tu peux venir
il ya franck gastambide ayane et dit je
suis sur un dos une meuf mais je veux
que vous la voyez avant exemple j'ai
besoin de l'aval des copains des copains
alors pas voulu resserrer donc on est
obligé d'aller avec lui donc on est
obligé de manger c'est déjà ça nous
coûte une tonne jeudi et après on voit
voilà votre sentiment
et après on lui dit où le laisse olive
asie voilà on lui donne un petit billet
aller manger tous les deux c'est vrai
c'est vrai voilà et on le regarde de
loin comme ça et se casser la gueule
parfois je me suis pris s'en rend même
fois je me suis retrouvé à faire des
soirées au départ on était 3 et après on
se retrouve seul face à face franck
gastambide et moi à regarder manico loin
entre indochine et la mode
mais on adore et on laissera jamais
tomber c'est bon on est comme ça qu on
un instant rien pour l'instant
alors moi tu peux pas savoir le nombre
de meuf qui me disent est ce que tu
connais malik bentalha est ce qu'il
pourra voir le numéro de quelqu'un
d'autre ça non non non pas comprendre ça
a été un succès en ce moment c'est
incroyable arrête pas et je vous dis
physiquement vous monsieur live sur le
tire-fesses de la bogossitude vers la
charrette quoi 10 800 à 2200 il ya des
surfeurs qui font rien arrête toi tu as
qu'il est est ce que vous avez avant
qu'on voit la bande annonce de mon
admirateur secret qui passera ce soir
sur m6 à 23h05
est ce que kelly vous avez un admirateur
secret qui vous regardent jeu est ce que
c'est un américain non à ses cuisses un
français sont normés merde on n'allait
pas français on s'est quand même bien
sûr vous avez on est quand même en reste
quand même en france allergique est mon
ami mais aussi ma famille mon papa
potins et oui c'est toi que j'admire en
secret la simplicité ta bienveillance
ton humour à toute épreuve
je souhaite ce soir te dire que je
t'aime et ça pour toujours quand tu veux
point d'eau mac et ta mère
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la dernière fois la der burgh ai dit je
t'aime c'est farouk c'est très mignon
c'est pas lui faire un petit bisou qui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fera sec mais tu enlèves le dentier
[Rires]
raymond admirateurs ce que la wii moi
j'en ai bien lu ça va très vite c'est
combien vous êtes bien la magie pas des
gars c'est à toi que je croise presque
tous les jours qu'ils me voient mais me
regarde si peu qui critiquent souvent
mon physique quand moi je rêve en secret
d'avoir un corps aussi gay n'est que toi
qui clame sans c'est qu'il n'a pas
didier lors qu'il a l'un des plus beaux
de paris à toi pour qui j'ai plus des
toits dans les yeux que n'en a jamais eu
thomas pesquet et qui ignore que je
regarde chaque jour motus en attendant
de pouvoir le soir venu lui lécher les
moules cyril jetez moi
regarde mise en scène jean therme 0 pt
en mêlée
[Musique]
non